have
covering the the book
and films
so that you've got
something to follow
on page 120
so we can
bypass that
the the film shows uh
even as short as it is it covers
how you enter for the ekyo
how you can apply
from the basic ekyo
use it in slipping down to the hand how
you can change it into a nikki o
or
mate and then it shows you how you can
go into the senkyo
so from ikiyo to senkyo on page one two
two one two three
the film
shows you the hand
sliding
past using the thumb
what you don't want to do
is
when you rotate it forward don't push
your arm so far that
when you turn the thumb
it has to come back to you in this sort
of backward motion it should go full
forward
hook down
and round you see without it moving so
round and down without it moving
do not hook down and come back
this is what most people do and then
they push it forward again
if you do that
as you come back
they could straighten their arm
come past your neck and throw you as if
like in a coke you naggy
the same way as a meroti door they could
step to the side
straighten their arm
and throw you down
so this is the reason for
using the thumb
in the nicu
and only going forward
if you find that you're
you've done this
you start to extend forward
then your timing has to be
to cut them down first you cut them down
but the bottom of the stroke
you need the thumb like this so you cut
vigorously
cut vigorously
and remember that their elbow
needs to be
higher than their shoulder
if somebody's a little bit stiff or a
beginner
they're not gonna
no reactions if you've been practicing
with someone on the mat for a little
while
they don't want the pain of the nikki oh
so they they tend to go down further but
somebody in a real situation
or a beginner or somebody who's stiff
or somebody who just wants to resist
they'll keep their shoulder higher than
the elbow and so your first action is
the ichiho and the ikyo cuts them down
so it cuts down vigorously
try not to lean with your upper body
over over this cut try to bend the knees
so bend the knees if you have to absorb
depending on their height
so
vigorous cut
at the bottom of the cut if you're going
to do the thumb for the eko control on
the hand
or the ekio to be changed into a nekyo
towards their ear
then the shoulder needs to be lower than
the elbow before
it's done
it's like bicycle pedals you know
this comes down
and this goes over like this
it's a rotation now
it's slightly showing that it's coming
back into me but i'm trying to within
the camera frame trying to show you the
rotation
okay so one cuts down
the other one
takes over
all right but you must not let them come
back into you
all right so please be careful watch
this move and watch yourself doing it
try it a few times just the first part
so cut them down vigorously at the
bottom of the cut the thumb's got to be
like this way up
so the last part of the cut you quickly
turn
use the thumb
to rotate to get the
hand now except same thing
with senkyo
but with saying here you have to be a
lot more skilled
you as you cut them down vigorously
as they start to go down instead of at
the bottom of the stroke the hand being
like this the hand keeps the same but
it's moved
to their
outer blade
it's moved to their outer blade
and then you take it
the same way as you do this exercise
sometimes in preparation at the
beginning of the class we do this
exercise
that's the exercise you're going to do
on them
so as you cut them down
you'll be able to get this
this hand
okay
so you'll cut them down
but on the rest it will slide to the
outer part of the hand
and you'll get them in a sankyo so the
bottom
the pages the book shows you
where to hold
the next point that you have to watch
changing from ekio
or
nickio
into sankyo
you've got them down the shoulder is
below the elbow
you're holding the hand
you're holding the hand the hand
of the fingers
tucked back
at this angle
you you have to then take your hand for
a mote
you're gonna well handler you have to
take the elbow hand off
and this hand doesn't won't have enough
power without using strength to hold it
and there'll be a gap between your hand
and your body
the picture shows
that
as you release your hand
you need to
as you release the hand you need to
follow that keep controlling the elbow
with this part of your
forearm
and it's like projecting forward it's
like projecting forward
so you take the hand off
and as you take it
off
it slips underneath
the arm so the elbows on top here so
you're going to let go and you're going
to
slide it like this
that's all about the chair you're going
to slide it like this
you can slide it like this and you're
gonna rub that arm
against their arm
in a forward direction
so you're gonna keep that momentum of
forwardness going the same way as this
pedal action
that action of forwardness with the
elbow
you take the hand off you slip under but
you keep extending that forwardness
so they can't get up it's like you're
keeping them slightly off balance all
the time
and then you can carry on and do the
same cure the the mote or the ura
i'll make a film on here on this ankylos
but more on the error because the error
everybody seems to mess up on the
footwork
and the development of this um
spiral
the spiral is like an ice cream cone
okay so
you need this
sort of helical understanding
to understand kaitenagi
set and urosenkyo
if you don't understand this you're just
pushing their arm up and down and
pulling it up and down
but uh the next film will be on the on
the senko and these points
but this is to cover the book so far
okay
keep studying the book keep studying the
forms don't be in a rush
and detail if this film is not
explaining to you an exact detail
let me know and um
we'll either zoom meeting have a zoom
meeting or i'll try and clear up on
another film thanks for your time